Why don't we go next to let's go to horse
from Illinois.
Horse from Illinois.
You're on the air.
Horse from Illinois, please, on mute, and
then you'll be able to talk to me, horse from
Illinois, you're on the air.
And last chance for horse from Illinois, you
are on the air.
All right, no more horse three, three shots,
is it?
Let's go to Kyle from Daytona Beach next.
Kyle from Daytona Beach, Florida.
You're on the air.
Hey, David, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Excellent.
Thank you so much for taking my call.
Pleasure.
So down here in Florida, things have basically
been wide open, the entire pandemic.
All right, you've covered Santos's handling
of the pandemic.
But what's what's concerning me is the the
chatter that that I'm hearing from my neighbors.
I'm actually a former white supremacist.
And I can I can say without any shadow of
a doubt that the rhetoric coming from the
right shadows the agenda of the white supremacist
movement, fourteen eighty eight, RaHoWa, racial
holy war and all that.
And when I saw the.
The Odel room at CPAC, it really shocked me
because after so many instances of of references
to white supremacy from the right.
Yeah.
It's not a coincidence.
It can't be.
You think so?
So let me just make sure everybody knows what
you're talking about.
So at CPAC, if you looked at the shape of
the stage from above, it looked like this.
I mean, it's a white supremacist symbol, but
what is the symbol exactly?
It's an odl room and and I hope people don't
get it confused with the with the religious
symbols of the elder fouth, dark and, you
know, pagan religious practices, this odl
ruin is is a modified thala room.
And there were there were mistresses in Germany
in the nineteen thirties that came to prominence.
And foremost of which was.
Von List, Guido von List, and he he put a
twist on the traditional religious runes and
the Nazis took these bastardized runes and
ran with them, the the old rune is one of
these bastardized runes that, you know, came
about through mysticism and through the emphasis
of, you know, a Germanic heritage that the
that the Third Reich emphasized.
And you just don't think there's any chance
that that's a coincidence at CPAC.
Well, there's absolutely no way, just like
when the former president referenced Henry
Ford's bloodline medic.
Yeah, exactly how are you going to reference
an obscure anti Semitic text?
If if you're not a part of the white supremacist
movement, and I've I've actually I've actually
had to meet with a gang sergeant in the county
that I live in to try to get my name out of
all of this insanity.
So I was going to ask you that.
So when you say you're a former white supremacist,
were you part of a of an organized group or
you were like just a general white supremacist?
Know the American Nazi Party was hatched full
member.
Wow, and how did you get out?
My my mother's.
My my mother's from Tennessee, but her father
was a professor and he marched during the
civil rights movement and when I started to
go farther and farther right now, keep in
mind, this is a woman who raised me on Rush
Limbaugh.
Right.
But when she but when she started to hear
white supremacist rhetoric that she recognized,
she told me that that's that's not how we
live.
And that and that that's and that's not right.
And she would quote the gospels, you know,
the read words from the New Testament.
And what's what's what's really wild about
all this is that the majority of white supremacists
believe that white people are actually Jews
and that Jews are our faith Jews because,
you know, everybody wants to be the chosen
people, right?
Yeah.
White supremacist generally believed that
the tribe of Dan or the lost tribe of Judah
somehow went to Denmark.
The Danes Dan, I don't know how they make
that connection is not based on science or
history or DNA, but they say, oh, well, we're
the lost tribe of Judah and.
Where the actual Jews and my mom started pointing
out the insanity, you know, how can you be
anti Semitic?
And claimed to be Jewish.
It's all pretty incoherent, yeah, and so so
but just in summary, because we do have limited
time.
So how old were you when you got into being
a white supremacist and how old when you got
out?
In my early 20s and I got out in my early
30s, OK, it's a decade.
Yeah, it was I spent the first part being
heavily indoctrinated and about the last half,
you know, very, very confused about everything
until logic and reason overtook the indoctrination.
Yeah, but what I'm what I'm concerned about
is.
The future of our country, when so many of
my neighbors and even my mom actually told
me this past weekend, people at the church
where I grew up, the I mean, people at the
church that I grew up at are are spewing anti-Semitic
rhetoric.
Yep.
Racist rhetoric, far right rhetoric.
And and their Bible thumpers know your right
to your right to be concerned.
Kyle.
I am glad you got out of it.
And I appreciate the call.
I do have to move on.
Let's let's plan to speak again, because there
are there are lots of folks hoping to chat
today.